foreign
[Music]
briefing for Wednesday January 4th I'm
Julie Chang for the Wall Street Journal
filling in for Zoe Thomas
the war in Ukraine is approaching month
11. and keeps forces fighting the
Russian military have managed to
accomplish something the Pentagon hasn't
going digital networking their Fighters
intelligence and weapons faster and far
more cheaply than the decades and
billions of dollars spent by the US
to be fair the defense department aims
for a scale security and bandwidth that
far exceeds Ukraine's Ambitions but are
there lessons the U.S and the West more
broadly can learn from Ukraine's ability
to Cobble together a virtual command and
control system on the Fly With Me Now to
discuss that is wsj Brussels bureau
chief Dan Michaels Dan thank you for
coming on the show Good to be with you
so Dan you've been keeping tabs on the
war in Ukraine and found that the
military there has essentially digitized
its fighting force on a shoestring can
you tell us what that actually looks
like on the ground what kind of things
are they doing ford Ukrainian soldiers
out in the field on the front line and
behind the front lines as has been
widely reported they're a pretty Scrappy
Force there wasn't much of a Ukrainian
military in a big way before Russia
invaded almost a year ago a lot of the
equipment is donated from countries in
the west but what the Ukrainian troops
have that is really unusual is the
ability to communicate with each other
and to get intelligence and targeting
information in real time in a way that
other
armies Underdog armies haven't had they
also have new technologies like drones
drones have been widely used by the U.S
by Russia by others but what the
ukrainians have done is taken drones
which for the US for example have been
very big and expensive almost like
airplanes and just taken cheap hobby
drones and turn them intools of War too
you mentioned that the Ukrainian Army is
able to communicate with each other in
ways that other Underdog armies haven't
how are they doing this combination of
things one of the most important things
is they're able to communicate using
satellites and that's uh for the most
part starlink which is uh Elon Musk
spacex's satellite Communications
operation they've donated some equipment
the US government has paid for some a
lot of Ukrainian soldiers have bought
their own starlink units and so they're
not reliant on cell phones they have
ability to communicate even when
everything around them is destroyed and
over starlink they're using some apps
that are pretty familiar to people like
signal encrypted Communications apps
they're also using apps that the
ukrainians themselves have developed for
things like targeting and for the
headquarters the bases command and
control centers to send information for
example targeting information to the
Troops at the front troops using these
high Mars mobile rocket launchers that
have gotten a lot of attention they will
get targeting information essentially
over a tablet or a cell phone and that's
being fed to them digitally from
headquarters it might be very far away
but it's incredibly precise so Ukraine
has a large Tech sector we've covered
that on the show before so from the tech
side of things that all makes sense but
was there anything else Health in
Ukraine that help them establish this
digital Guerrilla type Warfare so
quickly it was a combination of
capability and just pure need as several
people said to us when your country is
invaded and it's almost existential what
you get is not just military types and
not just military technology people but
everybody pitching in everybody bringing
something which may not be technology
itself but maybe a different way of
thinking about a problem several people
said to me that what's different about
the military technology efforts in
Ukraine versus what say the us or for
example the UK are doing is that you're
really getting the just some of the
smartest people in society applying
their brain power to the problems and
it's just a very different Dynamic from
say in the West in a peaceful Society
where those people probably aren't going
to be focused on Military technology
now let's talk about that
a little Terry's in the west like the
U.S the biggest difference from
militaries in the west is the scope and
the ambition of what's going on here
what the ukrainians are doing is is
emergency to react very quickly
what the U.S and some of its allies have
been doing has been going on for years
it's incredibly ambitious and much more
comprehensive than what the ukrainians
are doing so with ukrainians are doing
in some ways has even been enabled by
things that the U.S has done in the past
let's not forget that the internet was
begun as a U.S military project
um GPS was put in Space by the Pentagon
and drones were really supercharged by
the US military so what the ukrainians
are doing is cherry picking the cheapest
easiest to get off the shelf bits of
this and improvising an approximation of
what the US is doing but by no means
trying to copy the whole thing the
Pentagon is under enormous pressure to
make sure that everything is foolproof
and works perfectly the ukrainians are
doing this all by the seat of their
pants on the Fly just trying to gain a
little bit of an edge on the Russians
and given the the terrific situation for
the ukrainians there's a lot more
willingness to experiment and I've got
to imagine that if things don't go
perfectly people are a little bit more
forgiving than they might be if some
hugely expensive Pentagon system doesn't
work as it's expected to so are there
any lessons that the west or the U.S can
learn from Ukraine's tactics the most
significant lesson repeated To Us by
several people was the need and the
willingness to experiment and innovate a
few people we talk to who have
experience on both sides with the US the
UK but also with the Ukrainian say
what's really impressive about what the
ukrainians are doing is just their
willingness to try things so the biggest
gift for the West in terms of thinking
about military technology that is coming
from the really terrible fighting in
Ukraine is this laboratory that is
really being powered by the need to move
fast
all right wsj Brussels bureau chief Dan
Michaels thank you so much for joining
us today thanks a lot and that's it for
today's Tech news briefing for more Tech
stories check out our website wsj.com
I'm Julie Chang for the Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]